okay remember if you ever shop on
amazon.com you can use the link david
pakman.com slash amazon before you shop
it'll just send you to Amazon's website
and then any shopping you do will
support the work that we do very very
easy sends us a seven or eight percent
kickback from everything you buy
somebody over the last week streamed the
Batman movie with Jack Nicholson and
Michael Keaton I'll absolutely love that
movie I happen to think it is the best
Batman movie but there's this funny
story which I think I might have told
years ago about this movie when my
family first moved to the u.s. from
Argentina in 1989 and I believe this
movie came out either an 89 or early in
1990 I don't remember offhand I remember
going to the electronics Center I think
is the name of it on Damen Road in
Northampton Massachusetts I'm 99% sure
it's the electronics Center if not the
electronics store and getting a VHS
player and we had this Panasonic 20 inch
TV and we got this VHS player and we
went to Blockbuster and I was allowed to
make a recommendation as to the first
movie that we would be renting on VHS
and it was Batman with Michael Keaton
and Jack Nicholson and I've probably
seen the movie I don't know 20 or 25
times since it is an extraordinary movie
that I recommend but to whoever bought
it a great great great choice I don't
know which Batman this is a picture of I
know Val Kilmer
and Ben Affleck and Christian Bale there
have been so many Batman's at this point
for me Michael Keaton still the best
Batman and remember if you ever shop on
Amazon go to david pakman.com slash
amazon first and then the shopping you
do will support the show what's better
than that